there's some things are going to have a
big impact on that on that war
um
one of them is snipers
and the reason I bring this up is
because snipers in task unit Bruiser we
used very effectively against the enemy
the psychological impact of snipers
cannot be overstated we certainly got
reports
from the enemy the insurgents in ramadi
were horrified there's an equivalency
between a sniper and a roadside bomb in
that if you're out there doing your bad
guy stuff and you think you're going to
get away with you and your bad guy stuff
and you're not scared of anyone because
you kind of
operate without without any fear because
you don't even see you don't see any any
American forces around you're just out
there being a bad guy and you're out
there doing bad guy stuff you're digging
a hole in the road or you're maneuvering
to a fighting position or whatever and
all of a sudden your friend's head just
disappears